j'ai des belles décorations de Noël des
petites boules des moyennes boules
jusqu'au grosses trous c'est la déco du
magasin c'est pas vendre vous m'aimez
pas mais moi je vous aime bien merci
votre quoi
tu as vu ce que ton fils vient de
dessiner
peut-être qu'un jour il fera quelque
chose avec ça c'est quoi ton problème au
juste et dis pas que c'est parce que
maman est partie je te sens supporter à
manger
qu'est-ce qui cloche avec cette voiture
on s'est brièvement rencontré il y a
quelques années voici ma fille et bien
lui c'est mon fils ravi de vous
rencontrer ça ravi de vous rencontrer
aussi alors vous ramassez souvent les
dames sur le parking de l'église
regarde
oui mais je les utilise plus maman tu
récupères des trucs de mon carton noir
je fais que regarder
est-ce que vous avez une vieille poêle à
frire que vous utilisez pas et quelques
bières voyons d'abord si vous arrivez à
réparer la voiture
[Musique]
je ne sors avec personne en ce moment ça
tombe bien parce que moi non plus je
sors avec personne en ce moment si tu
veux avoir une fille comme ça tu dois
commencer à te conduire comme un homme
tu travailles à la chocolaterie tu fais
des dessins sans parler du fait que tu
vis toujours sous mon tour ici c'est
dont tu as besoin quoi de t'envoyer tu
as des gardes
[Musique]
ça faisait longtemps que je n'étais pas
sorti comme ça
pourquoi tu ne m'as pas dit que tu étais
sorti avec timide
vous avez trouvé ça bonsoir moi c'est ça
c'est mon noir et elle est incarnée
vraiment Bill
alors tu veux me faire monter sur des
patins à roulettes c'est bon il est
super mignon
[Musique]
maman
tout de même pourquoi tu es pas toute
seule c'est pas vrai Bill il a dormi
chez toi grand Dieu
vous avez beaucoup de talent vous
devriez faire quelque chose avec ça
c'est bien votre père non il pense que
c'est seulement quand on les gamins
qu'on doit appeler nos pères ou pas j'ai
commencé à m'amuser à 16 ans à nous tous
[Musique]
les deux jours pas tous les jours tu
fais toujours n'importe comment
[Musique]